(Intense choral music)
- I think I nailed that.
(Playful music)
- Let's see if I'm memorable.
I say I am.
Let's see what this
bullshit website has to say.
- Do you like chips?
- Love chips.
(Sounds of chip bags being caught)
- Open and eat them
without making a sound?
(Mysterious music, like tiptoeing)
- Shit.
- Am I allowed to use tools?
No.
- Shut up.
- Okay. Got it. Got it.
(Loud sound of chip bag opening)
- That's bad.
Oh, but I did it.
- Yes.
(Crunching)
(Chewing)
- That was pretty quiet, I thought.
- I'm being asked to
take a memorable selfie,
and I think I've got an idea.
I'm thinking ball pit,
if I, like, can fit in here.
- You've got furniture here.
This is a perfectly good tripod.
Ooh, god.
- God, I can't even see
what the fuck is happening.
God fuckin' damn it.
- Lift up you eyebrows a little bit.
- Then you've got to do
like duck lips, right, so...
- Lower the eyelids a little bit.
- Then I just try to
get like a good angle.
- You just lift up your face and, duh.
- I'm going to do my best Kylo Wren.
- Think that looks really good.
- Oh, man.
- So you're like the go-to
penis emoji to sext with.
Is that weird, cuz you're a ...
- I'm, I'm a woman?
I mean, nah, it's cool.
I wouldn't mind being used
in a conversation about
eggplant parmesan every
now and again, but ...
you know, I'm just happy to be in the mix.
- Yeah, I guess I don't mind
being used for sexting, either.
- People use you to sext?
- Yeah. Me and the speech bubble.
We're talking dirty.
Why? What were you thinking?
- Ah, it's really not important.
- Ew, like a weird poop sex thing?
Come on.
- What do you want me to think?
You are literally a poop.
- Okay. That's fair.
- Says computing.
- I think I'm probably
going to rate pretty low.
Whoa. What the fuck?
.751. Is that a good one?
- Memorability high. Whoa, awesome, .855.
- Whoa. Score .79.
- I just got a score of .88.
- I have a lot of selfies
on here. Don't look.
It says it's very high.
I got a .974.
- I think this website is
completely accurate now,
considering that I'm super memorable.
(laughing)
(Dramatic music)